Thank You Thomson one of our finest
actors and I think the performing bug
bit early on because I know you know
this picture it's you I don't know how
old you were but you clearly you are the
star of this show here they are
can you tell which one is then Judy it's
this one we have taken us off it off to
upstage the others I made my way to the
crown you read it
she looks so unimpressed that girl on
the right is Angela Beresford and she
couldn't stand the Middle's of
sandwiches say I can't eat this sandwich
I can't eat this and I can't take that
and that and that but she would eat the
bread
she had the bread okay you should make
her a bread sandwich right she thought
of it give her a low I think this one at
the end you who just didn't get the memo
about the costume at all her mother
hated going that will be fine
[Applause]
we've also got a picture of you I've
learned a little young performer in it
but you are quite young
now okay can i play shuttlecock I got
turns a lot you clearly did all over
when I was a kid and I also discovered
Sonnen which you know was supposed to
make your hair blond but when you have
brown hair it turns it red great with
this around the time that you decided to
pass yourself off as a musician mmm yeah
I my dad played the guitar and I would
take the guitar out of the case and look
around my neighbourhood with the case
because I've planted people to think
that I just like walk and just like look
at people me like oh you know and I
would just carry it around but you kept
things in it didn't you oh yes so
embarrassing I remember putting thinking
of myself
I should probably put vitamins in there
he's like I just had like Flintstone
vitamins I guess are very heavy to the
talking I know yeah I'm thinking ahead
yes now we have a picture of Jamie Foxx
young yeah but now how what age are you
here Oh
[Applause]
we got the same kind of hair well that's
a jheri curl right there I was 18 right
there that was 18 years old now that's
not a backdrop to make it look like
there's brick back there you know what
uh no I think that's real brother yeah
shell that good picture now if you
thought Jamie Foxx looked old there I
think you were
[Applause]
I don't I see no problem
are you about 20 years old there yeah
what was going on in your head I wanted
to look like magnum p.i I actually grew
a mustache in high school because I
played lacrosse and I thought it would
make me look more threatening it didn't
really it just made me look like a porn
star performer he was in it nothing to
start the day we late afford a place he
was at the other side of the pool weight
from the action Graham Norton air if
you'd like to see even more stuff like
that then hit subscribe or don't the
free world but I know what I do in that
situation